نحن امام هذا التهديد المباشر للمستشفيات
وخاصه مستشفى الرنتيسي والعيون والنصر
الاطفال والصحه النفسيه والان يتم التهديد
المباشر لمجمع الشفاء الطبي ان هذا
التهديد هو عباره عن قتل لالاف الجرحى
والمرضى في كافه مستشفيات القطاع نتعامل
في مع مرضى السرطان بصعوبه جدا بحيث اننا
حتى لا نستطيع ان ان نكمل لهم بروتوكولات
العلاج الكيميائي حتى كميه نقل الدم تم
استهداف العياده الخارجيه التي بتم فيها
اعطاء المرضى الا جراعات الكيميائيه ونقل
الدم تم استهدافه وخرج عن الخدمه هناك
مصابين من الطاقم الطبي بل نحن في كارثه
صحيه كبيره الجميع جميع الادوات الطبيه قد
نفذت جميع المحاليل جميع الادويه الت
تستخدم في تحضير ل العلاج الكيميائي قد
نفذت نحن مقبلين على
كارثه